[Music]
hello I'm Lisa Betts lacroix welcome to
the super power u podcast today our
guest is Alan Sakon and Alan is an
interlocutor and a polymath and the host
of the simulation series which is alive
a live show and a and a certain event
series and for the first time ever we
are live on location and we are
recording from the simulation series
studio so welcome so much to the
superpower you podcast Alan Lisa is such
a pleasure to be on your show thank you
for having me I'm so excited to
interview you it wasn't that long ago
that I was sitting in that chair and you
were sitting in this chair and I was
being interviewed for your show three
months ago your episode number 37 and
now we're on 160 this is a 59 so 160
will be posted later tonight amazing
it's crazy
yes so I always start my interviews off
with a question about my guests early
days and the reason is that I believe
that our childhood and our families of
origin lay a very important foundation
for who we become in the world so I'm
wondering if there's anything that comes
to mind for you from your early years or
your family of origin that you think may
have influenced the islands sake and
sitting before me now what would be
tough to identify something out of all
of evolution that produced me well we
can just stay within the time after your
birth mom's been a massive influence on
my life very grateful to have my mother
and my uncle they've just been massive
influences on Who I am and and I'm just
I'm very grateful for them and I'm very
grateful for who was before them and I
always say this but it's been a hundred
billion people that
lived and died on this planet to make
the world that we lived in live in now
so that's out of seven and a half
billion people alive right now that's
only seven point five percent of all the
people that have ever lived so just
thinking about the other ninety two
point five billion people is like you
know who were they what did they build
what did they do to have because you
know my mom and uncle weren't direct
contributors to the to the electrical
grid being made or to all of these crazy
healthcare advances that we have now or
to even you know the proliferation of
language across the planet so so just
I'm just so grateful for everybody
that's built the world that we live in
but a direct contributor I guess to my
past is for sure my mom and uncle will
say a bit more about them because I love
and appreciate your big picture and your
meta perspective and the global aspect
and we'll talk a lot more about how you
approach that that you know those topics
and from that way but I because my show
is really so much about the personal I
really would like to dig in a little bit
into who your mom was I mean really in a
really specific and maybe emotionally
present way like how does she make a
difference in your life yeah that's you
know it's interesting that I want to
stay on the point that you just
described which is that I frequently and
then we'll go back to what you asked me
to do I frequently go to the meta
perspective to this to this pale blue
dot perspective of earth looking at
Earth from the moon or from beyond it
and my insatiable drive you know even
you're like Alan like stay with me about
you and about how you were directly
influenced and I immediately just go
directly here that pale blue dot
perspective my insatiable drive to do
that is kind of what gives me that that
edge of speaking about myself beyond
myself yes because I don't actually you
know see so much benefit if talking
about just in my life when when we talk
about about the whole human perspective
we can better collectively move forward
but I also totally agree with what
you're saying so let's go back and what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna drive
jump in to say because I do believe that
mothers are pretty foundational my guess
is there's something about your mother
or you would not have raised her that
laid some aspect of the foundation for
you to bring that superpower of looking
at the meta yeah that's I don't know
what it is that's a good point I think
one of them was the DRI for my mom to
push me to read and that increased my
vocabulary that increased my imagination
we did so much science and math together
where you know that I was just doing
times tables like frickin G just going
hammering them out and it became just
like second nature for me you know when
I was playing too much inside of the
house you'd be like go outside and go
play outside and I would just go play
outside and go do random things besides
kicking the soccer ball around running
around exploring playing with the grass
and trees and water fountains and all
this stuff and I think that that those
little principles that my mom had were
were really crucial to me becoming Who I
am and I think that for a lot of parents
that are that are going through the
process of raising kids right now we're
kind of addicted to the cell phone cell
phone addiction and a computer addiction
and we can actually find quite a bit of
meaning and fulfillment in life by going
and learning how to handle interpersonal
relationships going out into nature
doing things like no put down the phone
and read read a book it will help
advance your life so much when my
finished interviewing Jordan Peterson I
asked him backstage afterward I was like
well how do I keep up how do I keep up
like intellectually and he goes read
like hell huh and that has also seep
deep into me now I'm just even if I can
only sit down and read for like 20 or 30
minutes I'm still flipping through as
many pages highlighting as much as
possible packing in that thought maybe
posting about it and going back to work
or going back to whatever else didn't
before what sounds like your mom not
only modelled but nurtured in a deep
deep way a love of learning so it sounds
like you have an insatiable desire to
learn in a curiosity that came directly
from your relationship with her and how
she
you interacted with you and spent time
with you we have a long lineage of
family members that are teachers or
engineers businesspeople so it just has
I think it I think it is deep in our
lineage but also I think a lot of it
also has to do with just you know you're
born into this world if your mind gets
expanded to a new dimension of thinking
of like okay crap I need to learn more
then what do you do with that you have
your full control you sit down behind a
computer and you're able to either
browse mindlessly or you're able to
specifically find a very high-quality
source of knowledge and you get that
choice every time you sit down and you
know now I rarely ever mindlessly and
when I do catch myself mindlessly I'm
like what am i doing and I go right back
to finding a source of knowledge this is
so strange because I'm always like
trying to figure out what is the next
question so okay what I'm gonna ask you
about that is it sounds like one thing
that's the one thing that sticks out for
me is that you're pretty young you're 25
25 25 and that's a lot of intentionality
for someone your age and not to be
dismissive of your age but I mean the
level of thoughtfulness self-reflection
and intentionality you just described
about how you take on learning is pretty
pretty rich and deep so is there
something related to your mother or your
uncle you didn't really talk about your
uncle yet and I'm wondering if there's
something that is specific to him in
terms of your contribution in your
development that may be different from
that larger familial piece mm-hmm yeah
so let's go to points there the first
point let's talk about how there was
this when we were just meeting with
Nehru costal at the ck-12 foundation
which is focused on free K through 12
education they had this kid interning
for them that was like 12 or 13 14 ish
years old and he was like my dad taught
me about the importance of finding high
quality knowledge and working on high
quality projects it's 12 13 14 years
right so that's what I'm saying is like
that parent that kid that is a really
good example of an idea of what kind of
a strong family connection and
connection to knowledge that can be
fostered throughout life and then just
to my uncle my uncle has been a massive
role of me understanding a couple things
really well time being something I'm
currently writing a lot about time I
thank him so much for teaching me about
the importance of time also about doing
things like understanding the way that
money functions in society economics and
politics both things like everything
from the way that capitalism is
functioning all the way to understanding
how things like greed and crony
capitalism have functioned in the world
and and and that's been very helpful to
my understanding of both Who I am today
and it's it's just ridiculous looking
back thing I really want to thank you
Lisa because I don't think enough times
we take time to take a breath and
reflect on our family and how our family
and our lineage has impacted who we are
and I really thank you for taking time
with me and just looking back and
understanding it so that's really cool
that you do this thanks yeah I think
it's really interesting and exciting and
as a person who's both the daughter and
a mother I think recognizing lineage and
recognizing the connections in both
directions is really profound and
special so thanks for recognizing that
for playing along with me tell us a
little bit more about the trajectory of
your life after your family I how did
you get who did you go to college do you
have a good experience there you know I
have a lot to say about college and
where education is going so I'm always
curious to know what fascinating people
have done in that domain yeah that's
really good that you asked about that
and I think we actually talked to you
about that when we host you on the show
yeah about the future of Education
that's ready dad really good things to
say okay so I was born in Sioux Falls
South Dakota and
until 17 then I went to University of
Minnesota in Minneapolis and then I
stayed there for two years until my
sophomore year I had tons of ideas and
passion for entrepreneurship and then
these guys were constantly coming out
for Silicon Valley and speaking at the
club and and I was like how do i execute
all these ideas and they were like kid
go move to Silicon Valley where
everyone's doing and so I I left took a
year of absence and I you know I thought
that I would I might go back but you
know I didn't end up going back it was
also a blessing that my you know my
uncle had already moved out to Silicon
Valley I believe one year prior to that
because he had also noticed that you
know working in engineering and quality
assurance engineering in Sioux Falls
versus in in Silicon Valley he was he
just figured out not only is he able to
work on more impactful projects in
Silicon Valley but also get paid a lot
more and so he's able now is out
Intuitive Surgical so do helping with
the surgical robots there and so he was
kind of a very important stepping stone
for me as well when I came out here I
you know immediately got a job
distributing fiber optics for AT&T
across businesses and residences and and
my uncle was a major like stepping stone
because I was able to stay with him in
Fremont and commute the egregious one
hour 45-minute commute into downtown San
Francisco every single day bus Bart Muni
- it was crazy and then a lot of reading
yeah yeah there was a lot of reading and
thinking but it's you know many times we
don't really think about kind of like
there's a really good quote it's that
the reason why I have such foresight is
because I stand on the shoulders of
giants and I totally stand on the
shoulders of giants I've I've had so
many of these amazing pillars slash lily
pads that I've been able to jump and
step on along the way and and work
together with but interestingly enough
after that transitioned from my uncle's
place it was like really it was really
solid that I ended up moving into
downtown San Francisco to live inside of
some there
very poor single room occupancy housing
units and SROs are very they're very
dirty and they they need a lot of work
and attention in San Francisco
and it's a big dichotomy between a
single room occupancy inside of a kind
of a dirty place
versus the three thousand four thousand
dollar-a-month one-bedroom apartments
that are built yesterday it's it's crazy
because that it was like you know it's
whatever it was like it it was like a
hunt goes like a 10 foot by 10 foot room
with a queen-size bed in it for like 800
bucks a month and that was that was that
was your space and it was interesting to
transition to that but we already had a
little bit of that in the dormitory life
back in University but I do think one of
the most important things about the
decision that I made to leave school and
come out here was that I had seen what
university life was like and to me it
didn't fit me and it was it's totally
okay that it fits for other people and I
learned a lot from it but also I learned
much more from being able to immerse
myself in the Silicon Valley just build
the future across so many different
areas and and I'm just you know very
grateful that I made that decision to to
come out here and it's just rocketed
it's been another rocket yeah and how
did you and did you know that you would
be doing something along these lines and
my context let me just say that from the
short amount of time I I've known you
and we were introduced by our mutual
friend Keith Powers who said you two
need to know each other yes and yeah
we're both wearing red shoes I think
yeah yeah that's right
because we're both like we want to be
eccentric unusual you know we like to be
different but so the thing that I
recognized in you there that I see in
you that I recognize in myself is this
desire and drive to both dig in and
learn from other people and but also
connect other people and highlight
people and showcase other people's ideas
and celebrate people yeah
I'm wondering have you always had
because ultimately I'm always driving -
what's your superpower and what's your
strength so I'm wondering to what degree
in other parts of your life you saw this
kind of skill set inclination that is
this you know personal connectivity
exploration community building I think
those kind of things that did you
imagine yourself doing something like
this and how did it come about it's also
a really good question I think that with
who I've become now I definitely never
thought that I was going to be hosting
people on a show that are scientists
entrepreneurs game changers in their
different industries it was probably
mostly the insatiable appetite for
curiosity but it's interesting because I
also find myself kind of both very
extroverted in my ability to just go out
and just tap right into someone's soul
and ask them the really important
questions about who they are and what
they're building into the world which
helps me a lot by parsing out at an
event who is really important that I
need to talk to because I think we get
lost in the Preta distribution 'he's all
the time and we don't even we're not
even aware that we're getting lost in
the surface level stuff and i like to a
deep right away
and then also just you know there's just
something about that introversion as
well in the ability to just you know
i've been to three ten day meditation
retreats going on the fourth one later
this year and just the ability to go
back inward it helps me look in a mirror
we struggle a lot with looking in a
mirror
and when i look in the mirror i tried to
objectively have a conversation with
myself about like hey how can I be
better than I was yesterday and then I
just didn't I go and I aim to do that as
well as I can and I think the
introversion like I like to read I like
to write I like to be by myself as well
so it's a really healthy in that sense
but
finding these different diverse minds
and asking them questions it's like it's
kind of like this whole you're just
serving your own need you're just
serving your own desire following your
own clear out curiosity probably that's
a big one of it and then also just this
like what we were talking about earlier
I mean can you believe that there have
been 92 and a half billion people that
have lived before us and they're 7 and
1/2 billion of us on this planet now
it's like if we've actually been around
that long and I'm 25 years old what do I
know really what do I know nothing well
you got a I'm sorry Donovan and for my
listeners we have Ron Vargas who is
going to interject now from his position
over in the producer booth and Ron yes
well you said it there Allen and in the
setting up for your question you know
that the planet in the universe is
billions of years old and what do I know
at 25 who's to say that you are not as
equivalent billions of years old as well
you are the product of billions of years
in the making
and you can and I just want to throw
that in there now I don't have any proof
but it's we are just we are billions of
years old not just 25 it's it's a you
know yeah that's interesting Ron's that
what Ron brought up and what you just
said to Lisa about this notion of some
sort of other collective energy that
exists within society that we don't
understand that well because we're so
locked into our own spirit of being that
we don't that we can't really bridge out
and we haven't scientifically
objectively tried to branch into what
that could be like so maybe you guys are
right that maybe there is some sort of
collection that this soul has
accumulated over time and and I'm able
to tap into that wisdom in some way but
just to follow up on this point about
age just like can is really like what do
I know you know what I do know is that
if I come into the conversation with
someone that has already built something
really fascinating into the world and
they're working on trying to eradicate
suffering or bring some sort of value to
the plan
you know what I do I go and I start
asking them tons of questions and
because I know that they're working on
something cool and they're really
important and I want to learn from them
and I want to highlight what they're
doing and show it to other people think
about it you look down at Hollywood and
Bollywood and India and there's just so
many of these different places around
the world that are entertainers athletes
actors actresses and and the someone's
got to do it and the films are normally
something that there is enrichment to
them but it's not it's not some sort of
like the people that we featured on here
are doing things like you know 3d
printing organs or building
decentralisation platforms for for
people's identity so you can never just
be taken off the face of the planet and
lose all of your assets to corruption
it's like just it's like things like
this that that that's why we're trying
to highlight these types of things
because moving forward how are we gonna
build a better world so that's why yeah
you know I realized that I kind of
jumped ahead without actually
introducing my listeners to what the
simulation series is and it's a show
featuring some of the greatest
scientists technologists entrepreneurs
and educators of our time and you
interview these amazing people that you
find and ask them really profound
questions and one of the things that
says on your website is that you're
rebirthing the public intellectual
inspiring you to build the future
yeah and that's sort of the context for
the show and some of the questions that
you ask are crazy things like are we
alone in the cosmos and who will teach
robots robots ethics and you know
ranging to what's the most beautiful
beautiful thing in the world and how do
we how do we balance the we are one
mentality with geopolitical leadership
and really profound and challenging deep
questions so I guess what one thing I
want to know is now that you've done 160
episodes what are some of the not
necessarily specific answers that you
take away but what's the meta what's the
meta learning that you've been able to
you know glimpse into
from doing 160 interviews asking those
kind of questions yeah that's good that
you mention that you you're talking
about the description of what we're
doing in the description of what we're
doing is kind of where I was just coming
from yeah as well and it's like this is
why we do it because we think it's so
important to talk about these things in
our world and now what have we uncovered
as we've been talking to 160 of these
people since January well we have
definitely learned that there is a lot
of interconnectivity
around all of these things that is that
makes so much sense to me you know that
makes so much sense because I'm just
listening to you start to think about
your answer and realize that you cannot
ask that level of depth in terms of
question with to that many people and
come up with a specific what you're
gonna get is a meta and Internet
interconnectivity seems like the
beautiful profound deep and you know
inevitable inevitable thing to be
uncovering so say more about that what
say more about interconnectivity as you
personally see it or as you pursue it or
you know interact with it now how does
that play out in your life or in the
lives of the people around you yeah
interconnectivity is such an interesting
concept yeah whatever
is teaching us that were locked in this
body and that I'm different than you
which I am there is some sort of in you
know energetic that is your ego and my
ego but then there is also the
dissolution of the ego and then the
oneness between us that we don't even
understand and so then there is this
kind of spectrum between those two
things and you know
and I think doing things like practicing
the continuous eradication of ego but
also bringing that you go up so that I
can at least talk on this show yeah it's
important the interconnectivity of the
different projects that are being built
into this world i we we we rarely
remember the butterfly effect but the
butterfly effect can be as simple as
when you're on the street and you're
holding a smile on your face and you
look at someone and they're kind of
neutral they see you smiling they start
smiling then they cascade that smile on
to other people later that day then they
smile and it just keeps going on the
butterfly facts very simple and it
doesn't need to be as complex as as
sometimes we explain it but another way
to view the butterfly effect in a more
complex way is maybe the way that maybe
the way that the technology proliferate
surround the world we never we never
really realized that oh man like you
know there's you know these smartphones
are gonna be in the hands of you know
three-year-olds and five-year-olds in a
decade and now they're in the hands of
three-year-olds and five-year-olds and
you know we don't we don't necessarily
know what the screen time is being used
for and that has a direct implication
onto the neural architecture of the
child that is being raised into the
world and we don't know what exactly
that's doing and but then there's also
the benefit of that three or five year
old potentially being able to access
YouTube videos that are teaching
language or that are teaching art or
music or other really important concepts
like science and all of a sudden that
three or five year old is just rocketing
their intelligence forward because of
this device so I think it's important to
understand butterfly effect can be
massive scale can be small scale and
also that can you believe the sheer
interconnectivity of what actually goes
on between humans humans and technology
different countries on the planet all
these people that we posted on the show
it's so fascinating that one of them you
know we'll sit we'll sit down and then
even during the episode we'll be like do
you know this person do you know that
person do you can we introduce you to
that person
and then all of a sudden all like we
have five introductions that we have to
make per episode to help people you know
achieve their goals and they meet they
go and meet these people and then they
then they've done they're like oh my
gosh you know sometimes it's like you
know it was just a great meeting but at
other times they'll be like we ended up
pursuing a really important goal
together and achieved it and you know
you just really wonder sometimes how a
multidisciplinary approach to knowledge
actually affects our understanding of
the world it's kind of that polymath
Polymathic approach because if we figure
out how biology and evolution can be
similar to blockchain and cryptocurrency
yeah then you know we're finding very
strange similarities and we're able to
kind of tap into a better understanding
of how reality works or how neuroscience
is maybe linked or related to artificial
intelligence or how you know some very
simple ones are like you look at an atom
and atoms 99.999% space you look at a
star and the planets in the solar system
99.999% space just some very interesting
things like that that just expand the
mind to new dimensions of thought and I
wonder what are these important ones
these dimensions of thinking that we
want to bring to kids at the youngest
possible age and in the most experienced
and relatable ways and that's kind of a
lot of what I'm writing about right now
and to me it's not really about content
it's about what I'd say I'd call
metacognition or metal learning skills
and we may have already talked about
that because something that I really
like to think about with regards to how
people learn and it's very relevant to
this idea being a polymath and drawing
on a lot of different topics and
intersecting them which is something
that I'm always fascinated by and so it
takes us to well what is the overarching
piece they had overarching thinking that
we get from doing all that
interconnectivity so yeah I'm wondering
if there are particular topics I know
from my show there are certain currents
that keep coming up in spite of myself I
have no idea that I'm not choosing
people on the basis of their gonna fit
into this theme but there's certain
themes that just come up over and over
again and I'm wondering if you're seeing
that
besides interconnectivity you already
raised interconnectivity but are there
other similar themes that just keep
showing up or that you keep recognizing
because a lot of it is through your lens
what's the lens through which you're
having the conversation hard work hard
work hard work yes I think it was you
know Elon that said that if you work a
hundred hours a week and someone else
works 40 hours a week that you'll be
able to achieve what takes them a year
you can do in four months and I was like
hmm
that's how people get ahead of each
other in the world that people work
their freakin asses off and sometimes
people catch themselves working a lot
and they're not actually getting the
wrong thing a lot done or they're not
any wheels yeah and but at the same time
it's like if you find work that doesn't
even feel like work it feels like it's
actually part of your life and your
passion and what you care about doing
every single day then it then why not
dedicate time to building that and to me
it's leaving behind and I think to a lot
of the guests that we have on the show
the pattern that we see is that the
amount of hard work and dedication into
building these projects it's about
leaving behind not a legacy for that
person but more about an impact on the
world that is beneficial and that just
goes way past themselves so I'm
wondering if that's another thing that
you see because I would say it is in my
show that there's a certain kind of
generosity or magnanimous you know kind
of orientation that people that I tend
to be attracted to hearing from yes
they're smart people and they're
accomplished people but there's
something that goes outside of their own
fulfillment of their own ego so I felt
that is a theme in the conversation you
know from the very beginning so I'm
guessing that might show up yeah
it's like bringing us again to this
circle of like I'm 25 you know you're
we're gonna live until we're a hundred
hopefully right and that's such a short
period of time the best we can do is try
and leave the world a better place
than where we found it and and help
others along the way eradicate some
suffering push to a better world a
better future ahead of us and it's just
like the whole time scale thing like I
what benefit would it be to to just want
to consume and just consume we talk a
lot about creation on the importance of
wanting to make and build and that being
such an important trait for for kids as
well as they find themselves being
birthed into this world I love that
vision I think it's it's a I'm touched
by your vision and your expression of it
you're very articulate thank you
I'm wondering if there's I've got to get
torch to your super powers and then wrap
up but I'm wondering you have
interviewed all these people and I'm
wondering if there are any specifics
that come to mind like anyone come to
mind as triggering some sense of like
well that blew my mind
mm-hmm anything any particular thoughts
or ideas that were really transformative
or really shifted something for you that
you can think of that someone someone
brought to you through your show and I
know it's kind of putting you on the
spot because sometimes recall is hard
but yeah isn't it strange how difficult
recalling yeah that we live day by day
week by week year by year and form just
these connections and are in our brain
about who we are and then when we're
challenged to recall things yeah I know
it can be challenging what comes up when
you recall things well I I'm I'm
definitely very blessed to have talked
to Jordan Peterson on our show and I
think he keeps a very high level of
civilizational overview of how things
are going on he also is his superpowers
that he's had just tens of thousands of
hours of talking to people and you know
that's that's what happens there's a
professor of psychology and and and and
in a clinical psychologist there's just
a you just take a lot of time with
people and understand pattern
you know I haven't had we haven't had
the chance to talk to Tony Robbins yet
but Tony Robbins also just has these 40
plus years of just understanding human
behavior understanding human patterns
and it's just a very high level view so
like something that a lot of the people
that we've had on the show have is this
high level view like why do you care
about decentralized AI economies right
yeah dan Gailey on the show and Dan
Gayle he's talking about well Amazon has
this silo of information and they don't
talk to Facebook silo of an information
they don't talk to Google silo of
information but when you open those up
to each other you will have profoundly
fascinating insights about yourself and
about the way that you communicate and
work in this world and so people have
bigger picture understandings of things
and that I think is a reoccurring
pattern of people that we have on the
show is big picture like why are we here
on this pale blue dot why does it matter
what are we gonna do moving forward how
do we build a beautiful world together
and let's figure that out because when
we don't have conversation you end up
like North Korea and when you do have
conversation you end up like South Korea
it's a very powerful example in the
world after the Korean War one's
inclusive one's exclusive and you can
see what happens across that border line
it was South Korea's like the 11th best
economy in the world and a lot of people
suffer in North Korea in many in many
ways and so if if if we as a planet
figure out how to work together in in a
better way which think we're totally on
path to do with more people having
higher-level conversations and projects
that they're working on
we will prosper will become
interplanetary and that's a major step
for us is to become interplanetary and
then I think another major step is for
us to figure out how me having something
doesn't preclude somebody else from
having something it's like digital music
if I can have access to a YouTube video
and you can have access to
YouTube video we don't have to fight
over it so if I can have access to an
apple and you can have access to an
apple we don't have to fight over it so
this this sort of idea of having enough
for anybody to be able to kind of summon
whatever they want whenever they want
actually is going to be huge for us so I
think these are kind of some baby steps
for us on this
you know maybe multi hundred year
picture that I hope to help pass down
and we're gonna do that through the
massive live events is we get to you
know sports stadiums of filling sports
stadiums our full-day multidisciplinary
events we're gonna throw in some art and
music and culture and networking and
meditation throughout these panels of
you know blockchain and AI and biotech
and neuro tech and globalization
geopolitics and emotional intelligence
and I have to just link back to you
again Lisa's just that you know you dig
out very interesting things from people
and I think that's another it's like a
superpower of yours is that you care a
lot about learning from somebody else
and you know how to ask really good
questions and and again you're not like
I focus a lot on the intellectual side
of things but I also care a lot about
emotion and feeling and energy but for
for you to ask us a first question like
you know talk to me about your mom like
talk to me about her influence on your
life right so I'm glad that you know
you're really you've refined and you've
tuned to something unique and that
that's a good one and I think Tony
Robbins actually does that quite a bit
I'm sorry he definitely deep he
definitely figures out about the
person's like mom and dad I'm like
lineage and well I think you're
recognizing that piece that he has done
so much work and I think I heard him say
something like he just sees the systems
there right there there's nothing he can
see the system because he's done it so
much so I you know I think that's that's
that's really clear and hearing him talk
I think I want to recognize in something
that you said that I really appreciate
that I also like as a basis is like go
deep right go deep whether it's from the
intellectual point of view or the
emotional point of view or the
intersection but Josh let's just keep
going deep and I want to give my
listeners a chance to know how they can
follow what you're doing so may
you can just talk about and I will
definitely link everything that you say
and everything you point to in the show
notes so people would be able to go to
the show notes to find it but just maybe
verbally give some idea about how people
can follow what you're doing and I know
you just described some of this
big-picture future vision of stadiums
and more enter intersectionality between
ideas and people yes for now where can
people follow the work that you're doing
yes simulation series.com is the easiest
way to follow our work we do our daily
show is livestream to YouTube and
Facebook just see youtube.com for such
simulation series facebook.com for
simulation series Twitter where
simulations show we post there a lot
Instagram simulation series on Instagram
and just personally you can follow me
it's just alan sake on comm alan socket
on twitter facebook Instagram etc
another interesting thought maybe for
your following is that there's there's
you know there's probably an
intersectionality between our audiences
in terms of how much they care about you
know listening to diverse perspectives
and people that are aiming to build the
future and so whoever is you know tuning
in from superpower you you know you know
join our community and from people
tuning into simulation join into the
superpower you community yam and we have
links on our video as well in the bio to
the superpower you podcast community so
definitely check them out as well and
then like let's get a little bit of
marriage habit maybe it'll be a little
bit of a civil union yeah but the best
way for your listeners to follow what
we're doing is on the superpower you
Facebook page and try to I try to post
stuff there so that'd be awesome now it
would not be the superpower you podcast
if we didn't not only dance around and
discuss in general terms your superpower
but really try to identify it and put
words to it because words are so
powerful so if I was to throw it over to
you what might you suggest as your
superpower it's a good question and I
have some thoughts yeah yeah I'd love to
hear your thoughts after this okay so
you know I think on episode 37 when we
featured you that I think that you had a
really good superpower
I think I asked you back and then you
asked me yeah I was like I don't even
remember what I am it was like hey I was
a seven year at 160 you're not gonna
remember that level is so good - like
iterate it kind of reminds me of like
you know when someone takes a picture of
you when you're you know in your days of
grade school and then you see like year
after year how your grade school picture
changes that's also kind of like what
this is is that your superpower is kind
of gonna change over time your essence
augments over time and so you know I
think right now what it is for me is
that it's this like when when when I
look I I see through a different lens I
think then a lot of people do and that's
one one of the things that I I see as
this augmentation - lens is that if we
if you guys have ever seen that video
where it's it takes you all the way from
the human perspective of like to people
talking and it takes you all the way
down to the Planck scale - the very
smallest scale the power of 10 video
powerful video and then it gives you all
the way back through the humans and out
through the cosmic scale to the
universal scale right I spend a lot of
my time thinking about the earth as a
pale blue dot and I really think about
it as like how I spend a lot of my time
in Google Earth and I Slee do so because
it it draws me to Africa it draws me to
Asia draws me to the to the scale of our
planet and you know when I learned about
the roaring 40s which is this you know
this win it's this win that wraps around
the southern hemisphere between like 40
and 50 degrees latitude and it's 17 to
27 miles an hour consistently and
there's no landmass blocking it so you
can sail around the earth in 40 days for
zero and if you can sail around the
earth in 40 days it's a pretty small
place so it's really important for us to
not only figure out how to take care of
it sustainably regenerative lis over
time but also to you know prosper and
get to the next rocks and and so I
really think about Earth
through this like lens through this lens
of like how do we augment civilization
in all these different ways when I walk
around I think about wanting to solve
problems and how we solve those problems
and that that that's just it's just a
different way of perception so I think
that's part of the superpower and then
also another part of the superpower is
just asking people get getting getting
past the surface level fast enough with
the surface level stuff and for the
people where they you know they have to
be tickled in the surface level for a
bid or their they only want to stay in
the surface level like that's fine like
do it but like if you want to
emotionally or intellectually get to
people's hearts and brains quickly then
go up to them and ask them hey what are
you passionate about what are you
building into our world yeah and and and
show them that genuine care for hearing
out their answer and give them eye
contact use your eyebrows these eyebrows
evolved so that you could have more
nuance in your emotional expression and
so you know you just raise your eyebrows
because we're like and you know that
shows interest and so so I think asking
powerful questions and wanting to break
through surface level conversations
another one of these superpowers and
building a really powerful future
together yeah I love it I mean some of
the things that come to mind and it's
hard to encapsulate I usually try to
encapsulate what some of the superpower
is in a phrase and that's a lot a
superpower to put into one phrase that
some of the things that I hear are go
deep go fast go fast go you know go deep
fast and also something like scaling
perspective or a scaled perspective or
you can just say big picture or
viewpoint but that's it's it's more than
that actually it's the simple or
superficial way to say would that your
superpower is a big big picture of you
but I think it's way more nuanced than
that and I'm not sure what the phrase
the phraseology is but it's something
like scaling the vision or something you
know I think good words that you just
helped me think of were yes scale and
then lens lens lens and scale and then
also depth to her especially in person
yeah absolutely well I so appreciate you
I appreciate appreciate the people that
you're bringing onto your show
how you're interacting with them and
what your intention is to give to the
world and how you're all about
connecting up all of our ideas and for
the good of the future generations and
our population here now thanks so much
for having me on your show Lisa it's
been a freaking pleasure yeah I love
being on you know someone else's show
it's so fun like I get to like not have
to ask questions as much and I'd like
that's fun but it also is like it's just
it's a true blessing to have Ron like
helping us produce and direct and yeah
it's a blessing having this network of
people like yourself and Keith who
connected us and all these other people
is just what the hell like it's we're so
great a great gratitude yeah can't be
angry and grateful at the same time oh
my gosh thank you for ending with that
because I think the idea of gratitude
the experience of gratitude something's
so easy to forget and it's so powerful
as a starting point for every
transformation that we want to make so I
thank you thank you thank you thank you
so much love thanks Lisa
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]